merci Michael Valley de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure
sénateur socialiste de la
Charente-Maritime vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées on va
longuement parler de la loi de
programmation militaire qui arrive
aujourd'hui au Sénat mais d'abord
évidemment vous suivez ce qui se passe
du côté de l'Ukraine et de la Russie on
l'a vu Vladimir Poutine qui a pris la
parole hier soir pour la première fois
depuis le recul de prix gaugine qu'il a
accusé d'avoir trahi son pays et son
peuple Poutine s'est posé en garant de
la paix intérieure de la Russie comment
vous avez compris
le fait qu'il soit obligé de s'exprimer
sur quasiment un aspect de de guerre
civile étant soit un aveu qui pouvait
difficilement ne pas faire et qui est
quand même le fait ça y est en fait de
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours si
vous voulez avoir une analyse qui soit
claire et transparente de la situation
c'est impossible d'abord parce que le
principe en criminologie que ce soit en
89 en 91 au moment de l'accession de de
Poutine au pouvoir sur la gare de
Tchétchénie et la suite c'est de se
tromper c'est à dire que on arrive
jamais à avoir les les renseignements
même quand les Américains disent qu'ils
avaient vu venir la rébellion de prigogi
on ne peut pas savoir si après coup
c'est pas une façon d'expliquer que le
verre est encore plus profond dans dans
le fruit ça peut être aussi de la
comment dire des enjeux de communication
pour pas dire de manipulation donc c'est
impossible de savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé quels étaient les buts entre
guillemets de guerre des uns et des
autres en revanche ce qui est
intéressant c'est de constater dans
quelle situation ça met le président
aujourd'hui et ce fois tout le monde
s'accorde à peu près et je pense qu'on
peut le dire de manière raisonnable
c'est que s'il n'était pas question de
l'ouverture d'une succession
préalablement puisque au moment de la
guerre en Ukraine on s'était dit il y a
peut-être des gens qui préfèrent
l'économie à la guerre et qui vont peser
tous leurs poids et ce qui va avoir les
oligarques avec lui bah oui il a des
égards avec lui parce qu'il détient
d'une manière ou d'une autre c'est un
régime corrompu pour pour faire pour
faire simple mais là maintenant on peut
penser que il y a différents clans qui
vont apprécier les choses de manière
différente ça veut dire qu'il est
affaibli l'animaire Poutine pour pouvoir
est en train de vaciller vous avez
parfois des retournements de situation
et je pense notamment aux événements qui
ont eu lieu en Turquie plusieurs mois
avant la dernière élection
présidentielle qui a vu Erdogan par un
coup de de faire politique retourner la
situation durcir les choses
malheureusement et finalement infinie
dans les urnes quoi qu'on en pense
sortir pas affaibli sortir plutôt
gagnant de la situation la visiblement
ce n'est pas le cas pour l'instant mais
les élections en Russie l'année
prochaine et on va voir comment le
quelles conséquence pour la
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui est en
cours est-ce que l'armée russe est
affaiblite moi je suis pas en mesure
d'analyser le fait de savoir si la la
puissance de feu la capacité de de
résister à la tristesse les munitions
qu'ils peuvent produire ou qu'ils
avaient prévu
son nature à faire en sorte que on ne
sentent que l'épaisseur du trait
du fait de ce qui vient de se passer ou
bien si au contraire il peut y avoir une
espèce de débandade le moral compte
quand même
énormément dans la guerre énormément
donc la valse hésitation de certains
militaires y compris de base sur le fait
de savoir s'il fallait s'embarquer dans
une aventure rebelle ou rester fidèle au
pouvoir enfin c'est quand même c'est
quand même comment dire pas la meilleure
des situations pour mener pour mener une
opération enfin pour mener une guerre
néanmoins il y a que dans les faits
qu'on le verra il est normal que le
président Zelinski en réjouissent parce
qu'il y a aussi la côté du le côté de
l'opinion publique et du et du moral des
troupes
qui a pointé la faiblesse de la Russie
et puis il a redit comme il dit il en a
profité pour redire il est maintenant
temps de fournir toutes les armes
nécessaires dont les chasseurs F16
qu'est-ce qu'il faut répondre à ça il
aurait tort de il aurait tort de ne pas
le faire parce que ce qu'il faut qu'il
donne à comprendre à ceux qui lui
fournissent les armes dans une guerre
mondiale dans l'univers des forces non
pas encore tout donné bon comme aurait
dit l'autre et donc il a raison de le
faire et de le faire comprendre
peut-être qu'il suffit de quelques
engins supplémentaires pour faire
basculer c'est son rôle de donner cela à
penser maintenant est-ce que tu es un
bon vue militaire et stratégique c'est
le cas bien évidemment les Occidentaux
et les Américains ne lis ça de très très
près il faut lui donner ses avions
moi je pense que il y a
une analyse en temps réel à faire sur le
risque coût bénéfice dans le fait de ne
pas entrer en guerre parler de la LPM
tout à l'heure nous annonce qu'on est
dans une économie de guerre on n'est pas
dans une économie de guerre c'est pas ça
une économie de guerre on les donne au
moins que nous ne sommes pas en guerre
et qu'il faut bien garder une gradation
parce que si un moment devait avoir des
événements imaginer une prise de
contrôle par des factieux en Russie on
l'aurait pas dit il y a trois jours ça
là je le dis aujourd'hui parce que
finalement l'hypothèse paraît moins
délirante même si je pense qu'elle est
peu probable
imaginez cela et que derrière on est des
gens qui ne s'encombrent pas de la
lecture des traités du droit
international qui sont donc en tout cas
encore moins que Poutine aujourd'hui il
faut garder une gradation dans tout ça
maintenant s'agissant de l'Ukraine dans
la mesure trempée comme on l'est dans le
soutien l'Ukraine et fort heureusement
il y a peut-être un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels il faut ne pas
mégoter après la question de l'aviation
c'est le risque de l'utilisation et du
débordement du conflit et on va parler
de la LPM la loi de programmation
militaire vous le disiez puisqu'elle
arrive cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat on va d'abord voir ce que
contient ce texte avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alexandre tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Michael bonjour
militaire qui va être examinée par les
sénateurs elle prévoit une hausse
budgétaire inédite pour nos armées sur
la période 2024 2030 le budget de nos
armées s'élèvera au total à 413
milliards d'euros une hausse de 40 % par
rapport à la précédente loi de
programmation mais qui s'inscrit dans un
redressement progressif de nos moyens de
défense depuis le début du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron par
exemple en 2017 le budget des armées sur
l'année était de 32 milliards d'euros
cette année il s'élève déjà à 44
milliards d'euros et en 2030 il devra
donc atteindre 69 milliards d'euros
alors une grande partie de la classe
politique et assez unanime sur cette
hausse budgétaire mais la question c'est
à quel rythme on passe de 44 milliards
d'euros cette année à 69 milliards en
2030 et en commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense et bien les
sénateurs ont déjà choisi d'accélérer
cette hausse budgétaire
le gouvernement nous présente une loi de
programmation militaire qui jusqu'en
2027 continue à dépenser 3 milliards et
puis les 100 en quelque sorte l'effort
au nouveau président de la République
qui viendra en 2027 or nous nous pensons
que c'est maintenant que nos forces
armées ont besoin d'un rehaussement de
leur de leur plan de charge de leurs
activités de leur matériel et donc nous
avons proposé un amendement qui lisse en
quelque sorte cette somme considérable
et va permettre de dépenser non pas 3
milliards mais 3 milliards 6 chaque
année
tout en restant dans la même enveloppe
et Alex a commencé en matière de défense
c'est la gare en Ukraine la France
continue de livrer des équipements
militaires à l'armée ukrainienne et cela
a un coût et dans ce contexte
géopolitique inquiétant cette loi de
programmation militaire permet de faire
des investissements supplémentaires dans
notre dissuasion nucléaire également de
moderniser nos moyens de lutte anti
drone et puis ce texte il va aussi
servir à financer le porte-avion
nouvelle génération le PNG qui va
remplacer le porte-avion Charles de
Gaulle alors ce PNG il pourra accueillir
2000 marins il pèsera 75000 tonnes il va
abriter deux mini centrales nucléaires
il sera construit entre 2026 et 2037 et
forcément il aura un coup écouter le
ministre des armées sur ce point
le PNG est une classe à 10 milliards
d'euros et en revanche chez les travaux
qui vont être menés dans les 18 mois qui
viennent qui va vous permettre d'affiner
les sommes
que j'espère pas la hausse évidemment on
se paye aussi il faut qu'on le
reconnaisse tous ensemble notre
autonomie française c'est-à-dire que
forcément si on a acheté américain ça
coûterait moins cher il faut s'y mettre
les pieds dans le plat tout ça coûte
aussi un peu plus cher parce que c'est
franco-français en autonomie et que
c'est lié la dissrusion voilà un
porte-avion français à 10 milliards
d'euros noter que lors de l'examen de
cette loi de programmation militaire à
l'Assemblée nationale et bien les
députés ont ouvert la voie la
construction d'un deuxième porte-avion
Michael Valley d'abord question simple
est-ce que les sénateurs socialistes
sont plutôt enclins à voter cette loi de
programmation militaire
sur les sujets aussi importants il n'y a
qu'une que le groupe peut se présenter
au vote je pense il y a pas de 4
consciences au sein du groupe sur la
programmation de la LPM vous dire le
résultat avant le débat non je ne le
ferai pas on est plutôt enclin à
accompagner le mouvement mais il y a des
amendements qui ont été adoptés en
commission tous n'étaient peut-être pas
tous n'avait peut-être pas l'heure de
plaire au ministre donc on verra bien ce
qu'il en reste en fin de de discussion
sur le sur le vote et ensuite il y a la
question de la CMP et notamment sur
certaines exigences qui a exprimaient le
président de la commission des frères
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées et dont on va voir s'il va
classer MP c'est la réunion entre
députés sénateurs pour se mettre
d'accord sur le texte voilà c'est ça qui
qui normalement va se tenir parce que le
texte ne sera pas identique et on va
voir jusqu'au bout si si tient le le
texte en tout cas les grandes lignes
tels qui sont sortis de la commission
frères étrangère et de la défense du
scénario et je pense qu'il y a assez peu
de visibilité sur ce point là et
qu'est-ce qui vous pose principalement
problème c'est la il y a trop de
dépenses qui sont portées après 2027
quand même parce que avant de rentrer
dans le détail de savoir combien coûte
la modernisation des drones combien
coûte précisément à nouveau porte-avion
et vous savez que pour avoir ce genre de
d'information il faut en faire en
commission il faut en demander au
ministère de des armées parce que
spontanément au Parlement français on ne
vous dit pas comme dans d'autres
Parlement
occidentaux ben écoutez ça va être temps
et vous pouvez vous exprimer et essayer
de de choisir il y a eu ce qu'on appelle
une revue nationale stratégique nous
nous aurions préféré un livre blanc
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que un
amendement en commission a été passé sur
sur le fait de demander un livre blanc
dans quelques années au moment de la
l'évaluation de la LPM une revue
nationale stratégique au début tout le
monde devrait être associé ça a pris le
chemin d'être dans des espèces
d'ateliers ou un peu plus j'imaginais
qu'on nous allait nous mettre les
post-it les gommettes et les et les
stabilos finalement la Commission au
Sénat a refusé de participer à
l'exercice on a monté nos propres groupe
de travail mais enfin tout ça a été fait
un peu à la va-vite et pourquoi parce
qu'il faut quand même rappeler que la
LPM actuelle n'est pas allée jusqu'à son
terme donc la première question qu'on
peut se poser c'est qu'est-ce qui
justifie vous avez évoqué il y a la
question de la guerre en Ukraine mais si
la guerre en Ukraine rebat
fondamentalement l'ensemble des cartes
de des armées françaises c'est qu'il
aurait fallu peut-être même changer de
modèle et là on est dans une continuité
parce qu'on fait une LPM deux ans avant
la fin de la LPM précédente et que
c'était pas le moment de faire une LPM
de rupture ça pose aussi peut-être la
question du budget parce que la
précédente votre programmation militaire
vous le disiez c'est 2019-2025 il y
avait 295 milliards là c'est
2024 2030 413 milliards est-ce que du
coup c'est 413 milliards sont en trompe
l'oeil comme ils chevauchent la
précédente
la réponse est un peu dans la question
c'est ce que vous voulez ce que vous
voulez m'amener vous avez raison parce
que dans la façon d'annoncer les
chiffres il faut prendre je vais pas
dire se méfier mais enfin encore que le
parlementaire il est là pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement il est par
définition méfiant mais il faut bien
avoir en tête l'idée du chevauchement il
y a la question de qui n'existait pas de
la même façon sous la LPM précédente et
puis il y a la question de savoir à quel
moment la bosse se situe
chronologiquement et là cette nouvelle
LPM elle arrive à un moment où nous
aurions dû avoir une bosse en 24 25 et
comme on remet tout à plat la bosse et
redécalé et accrochez-vous elle est
décalée après la fin du mandat
présidentiel donc là-dessus il y a une
quasi uneanimité au sein de la
Commission à faire des étrangère en tout
cas entre différents groupes de la
majorité sénatoriale ou de l'opposition
pour penser que c'est un peu gros et que
comme l'exprimer Christian Cambon il y a
des points sur lesquels on n'a pas envie
de de lâcher j'ajouterai à ça que quand
même dans la revue nationale stratégique
d'une part et dans le rapport annexé qui
d'ailleurs est fait pour être lu grand
public c'est pas comme un texte de loi
des fois il faut s'y retrouver dans les
alinéas les renvoie les suppressions
mais la revue nationale stratégique
d'une part le rapport annexé d'autres
parts il y a quand même un certain
nombre de concepts qui je vais qui ne
sont pas fumeux comme ils devraient
l'être c'est pas grave des fois d'avoir
des concepts
un peu fumeus parce que ça permet
finalement à tous les partenaires de s'y
retrouver mais ils sont pas fumeux comme
il faudrait qu'il le soit juste pour
qu'on soit bien clair après alex va
rentrer dans le détail mais ce qui vous
pose problème c'est un que la
trajectoire soit trop reportée après
2027 donc avec un risque après le mandat
présidentiel avec un risque
effectivement ce ne soit pas effectif il
y a cette histoire de chevauchement qui
fait que les hommes ne sont peut-être
pas exactes et il y a le problème que le
Parlement n'est pas assez associé bien
sûr
concrètement quelles sont les priorités
selon vous dans nos investissements
militaires est-ce qu'il faut faire
évoluer notre modèle d'armée
il faut pas se précipiter pour faire ces
choses là et les faire mal c'est à dire
que poser une LPM là maintenant un petit
peu plus d'un an avec le déclenchement
d'un conflit dans la plaine européenne
pour parler de manière géopolitique et
avec tout ce que ça peut impliquer de
bouleversement dans l'ordre mondial et
compris dans le droit international qui
est assez répercussions sur le droit de
la guerre c'est probablement pas le
moment de d'absolument tout remettre à
plat et pour autant il ne faut pas
vendre cette continuité ce changement
dans la continuité je crois que c'est ça
le c'est ça le l'expression non c'est
l'effort dans la continuité il faut pas
le vendre comme quelques il faut pas le
vendre comme une rupture ce qui est
quasiment le cas parfois dans certains
propos de la revue nationale stratégique
et ça nous fait courir le risque à force
de dire qu'on est une puissance
d'équilibre quand je parlais de concept
parfois un peu que chacun peut entendre
comme il veut il faudrait pas que ce
soit finalement un jeu d'équilibriste où
on ce qu'on appelle parfois et je ne le
dis je n'ai pas cette conception de
l'armée française mais une armée bonsaï
qui serait équipée dans l'ensemble des
domaines mais c'est la question que pose
ceux qui pensent moi j'y crois pas un
deuxième je crois pas nécessaire un
deuxième porte-avion mais c'est le
risque d'être doté un petit peu partout
mais comme on n'est pas doté de manière
puissante ou plus que certains autres
États bah oui on peut être nationcadre
sur certaines interventions mais on
n'est pas forcément chef de fil dans tel
ou tel domaine et ça c'est un vrai sujet
mais qui doit être débattu mais pas
seulement au Parlement y compris dans
l'opinion publique sur la question de la
dissuasion nucléaire ce qui fait que la
dissuasion est à son bon à son bon
niveau et à son bon étiage c'est un
débat qui doit pouvoir avoir lieu vous
avez des spécialistes qui considèrent
que la dissuasion nucléaire elle ne
serait pas moins efficace aujourd'hui si
elle était un peu plus contingentée et
qui a eu lieu à l'assemblée qui a divisé
la gauche d'ailleurs cette question de
la dissuasion nucléaire quel est votre
position est-ce qu'il faut revoir la
doctrine nucléaire alors
d'abord le ministre le Cornu a pour
habitude de citer le général de Gaulle
à toutes les phrases au début à la fin
au milieu ça serait bien un qu'on
affiche la paix à ceux qui sont plus là
pour s'exprimer et deux qu'on est quand
même en tête je vais faire le contraire
de ce que je viens de dire que le
général de Gaulle il a su toujours
rompre soit avec les visions de l'État
majeur soit sur la question de sur la
question des engins blindés soit sur la
question du matériel soit sur la
question de la communication avec le
passage à la radio donc il faut aussi
savoir rompre de temps en temps
néanmoins la diffusion nucléaire elle
reste fondamentalement le premier étage
mais qui ne se suffit pas lui-même on a
trop dans le texte de la revue nationale
stratégique ou dans le rapport annexé
l'idée que à partir du moment de la
dissuasion nucléaire il y a tout un tas
de menaces qui ne d'État qui ne
s'applique plus à nous non la dissuasion
nucléaire je pense qu'on doit la
repenser et simplement pour terminer on
entend dans certains discours il y avait
un documentaire cette semaine je crois
sur votre chaîne ou sur LCP où j'étais
très étonné d'entendre des anciens
présidents de la République expliquer
leur rapport à la diffusion nucléaire et
tout se dire en plus pour pas être
utilisé il faut surtout pas le dire en
tout cas un président ne devrait pas
dire ça c'était pas lui
un dernier mot puisque évidemment la
question qui se pose en plein en pleine
guerre en Ukraine c'est est-ce que notre
armée est aujourd'hui prête à faire face
à un conflit de haute intensité mais
est-ce qu'il existe d'un point de vue
géopolitique en regardant depuis la
chute du mur et en regardant aussi la
géographie telle qu'elle est dans la
question de la pleine européenne de
l'océan de la question de la
Méditerranée est-ce que nous avons un
risque de haute intensité avec l'idée
des chars qui traversent et qui arrivent
jusque là qu'est-ce qu'on appelle la
haute intensité en France il faut pas
être naïf on a un nombre de menaces qui
est énorme qui est exponentiel
d'ailleurs les moyens nouveaux donnés
aussi beh au drone il faut le faire s'il
faut se mettre au goût du jour mais la
haute intensité et puis moi franchement
les concepts au bout d'un moment je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire la haute
intensité c'est la guerre dans ce cas la
plus moche voilà et quand c'est hybride
ça veut dire qu'on n'utilise pas que
l'artillerie ou les bombes on utilise
d'autres moyens que la technologie
maintenant avec un mélange civil
militaire il faut arrêter de se payer de
de concept et bien évidemment l'idée
d'une armée française
la question se pose et on n'a pas trop
les réponses notamment sur la question
des munitions qui n'est pas un sujet
tabou quand on donne des munitions
ailleurs il faut qu'on en récupère par
ailleurs et c'est peut-être aussi pour
ça qu'elle était lancé l'idée de
l'économie hier on a donné à l'Ukraine à
affaibli notre armée non ce sont des
choix à l'instant T parce que l'Ukraine
ça renforce la défense européenne mais
donc c'est pas assez bien la France il
faut pas le prendre comme ça je laissais
au RN qui est en quête de concept lui
aussi tout aussi fumeux mais simplement
il faut avoir en tête que ce qu'on
appelle l'économie de guerre en fait
c'est une façon de dire on doit être en
capacité de produire à l'instant T si
jamais on entre en économie de guerre ça
que ça veut dire il faut pas se payer de
moi avec ça
merci Alex à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure on évoquera la popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron du RN de la nuque ce
sera le baromètre doxa en découvrir
assez avec vous Alex on va continuer à
parler de cette loi de programmation
militaire et on va voir l'actualité dans
votre département on va aller retrouver
Jefferson des sports qui est grand
reporter politique et défense à
sud-ouest bonjour Jefferson merci d'être
avec nous on va parler du séisme qui a
touché l'ouest de la France il y a
quelques jours mais d'abord puisque de
Jefferson vous vous maîtrisez bien
évidemment ces questions de défense vous
les reveniez sur un des aspects de la
loi de programmation militaire
oui bonjour Michael Valley oui restons
sur cette LPM parce que l'empreinte
défense est forte en nouvelle-aquitaine
avec la base aérienne de Mont-de-Marsan
la base école de Rochefort dans l'autre
département et les Forces Spéciales
terre dans la région simplement la
priorité de cette LPM vous en avez
évoqué plusieurs mais à celle du
renseignement avec la volonté de
réinvestir fortement de doubler les
crédits dans le renseignement est-ce
qu'il y avait urgence Michael Valley à
revenir sur ce terrain-là est-ce qu'il y
avait des lacunes dans le renseignement
français le problème du renseignement
c'est que vous avez deux facteurs il y a
un facteur technologique où on ne peut
pas se permettre d'être à la traîne et
sans enfoncer une porte ouverte toutes
les questions d'intelligence
artificielle ou de traitement le plus
automatisé possible ou d'algorithmes
dans le respect des libertés publiques
sont des domaines d'investissement on
peut pas se permettre d'être en retard
en fait c'est pas qu'on je pense que
c'est pas qu'on était en retard c'est
qu'on est obligé de se tenir à niveau et
dans le renseignement ça c'est la règle
vous avez le facteur humain et le
facteur humain il est il est fondamental
en termes de formation de recrutement
d'avoir des profils qui évoluent avec le
temps c'est pour ça que je suis toujours
épaté moi d'entendre des responsables
politiques qui s'alarent du fait qu'on
apprenne des langues étrangères en
France ou que des personnes qui l'ont
pour langue maternelle ou de
grands-parents le pratiquent en France
on a besoin de tout ça donc dans le
domaine du renseignement oui je vous
ferai remarquer ça sera peut-être
l'objet d'une de mes interventions dans
le cadre de l'examen de cette LPM que on
en a plein la bouche pour le dire comme
ça de l'OTAN et du partenariat avec nos
alliés historique que sont les
Américains il y a à peu près 18 mois de
ça les américains ils nous ont fait
passer sous le nez un contrat à 50
milliards d'euros sans que nos services
de renseignement ne le voient venir
aucunement donc soit les responsables
politiques ont préféré passer pour mal
informés que pour pas capable de de
mettre à basse ce coup de poignard soit
on était en été effectivement mal
informés donc on a de toute façon la
nécessité de se tenir à niveau et puis
il faut pas oublier la menace la menace
terroriste parce que la dissuasion
nucléaire dont il est dit dans la revue
nationale stratégique qu'elle protège
des menaces de des autres États
souverains ce qui n'est pas vrai on
pourrait avoir un débat là-dessus un
jour en tout cas elle ne protège pas la
dissuasion nucléaire contre la question
du du terrorisme ou contre la question
de de trafic ou de d'action hostiles qui
sont déstabilisantes
on va revenir avec vous sur cette
actualité qui a ce terrible séisme qui a
frappé l'ouest de la France était une
saison
oui bien sûr Oriane et Michael Valley le
sait le 16 juin la terre a trembler dans
le Sud-ouest et plus particulièrement au
Charente-Maritime avec ce tremblement de
terre évalué entre 5,3 et 5,8 sur
l'échelle de Richter le lendemain Gérald
Darmanin a annoncé une procédure
accélérée et de reconnaissance de
catastrophes naturelles et le fond
d'aide au logement d'urgence a été
activé Michael Valley est-ce que ces
mesures sont pleinement à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui est-ce que les crédits
seront au rendez-vous pour les sinistrés
moi je me suis rendu sur place
jeudi dernier pour aller voir certaines
communes en l'occurrence les les plus
touchés et je peux dire que de manière
spontanée unanime je suis allé voir
aussi les pompiers au PC à la Laigne
d'ailleurs ils ont à la fois du matériel
et une façon d'agir qui est très
impressionnante ils étaient partout
encore sur les toits tous les maires que
j'ai vu ont loué l'action des services
de l'état des services de secours de la
gendarmerie des forces de l'ordre et des
pompiers le ministre a très bien fait de
venir et on la remercie parce que
il faut noter ça il aurait pu ne pas
venir il y a quelques petites
imprécisions qui demandent à être levées
mais après c'est dans la mise en oeuvre
sur les questions de catastrophes
naturelles sur le fait de savoir qui
paye le relogement pendant 6 mois ou
j'ai vu des administrer qui n'y voyaient
pas encore tout à fait clair mais les
maires sont tout à fait en mesure de
l'expliquer et donc il faudra voir sur
le long terme c'est ce qu'on s'est dit
avec les collègues mer ils sont tous un
peu allés voir ce qui s'est passé
visiblement dans la Drôme il y a je
crois deux ou trois ans si je ne m'abuse
je crois que c'est dans la Drôme et où
ils étaient un peu inquiets du fait que
ce qui est annoncé au départ ne suis pas
forcément toujours aussi vite mais ça ce
sont des questions de conduite de de
projet et ce que j'ai dit à mes
collègues c'est que bon les services de
d'extrême urgence ils sont là ils font
ça très bien sur le moment mais
maintenant ça va être à nous tous
ensemble de suivre tout cela je pense
autant au département à la région
qu'aup parlementaire et puis aux élus
locaux voilà dernière question que
Jefferson oui est-ce que on se sent pas
démuni face à un tel phénomène un séisme
la Charente-Maritime n'est pas
nécessairement une terre de tremblement
de terre justement est-ce que le enfin
les bâtiments ne sont pas non plus
prévus pour résister à des secousses
extrêmement forts donc voilà est-ce
qu'on est plutôt diminue ou est-ce que
ça résonne comme une prise de conscience
Michael ça tremble en Charente-Maritime
et depuis toujours et depuis longtemps
mais pas dans ses proportions là moi
dans ma commune il y a eu un tremblement
de terre au printemps 2016 dont je me
souviendrai longtemps mais moi je n'ai
pas senti mais sur le sur le moment ça
avait fait beaucoup parler et j'habite à
côté d'une commune qui s'appelle La
Tremblade vous voyez c'est certainement
certainement pas pour rien ce que j'ai
noté la première chose c'est que et on
l'a vu au moment du séisme en Turquie
qui était sans commune mesure c'est que
quand les choses sont faites dans les
normes et qu'il y a pas la corruption
qui se met par dessus ou ou l'absence de
responsabilité des entrepreneurs ça
tient plutôt bien dans la commune de la
laine que je suis allé visiter les
constructions les plus neuves le maire
me faisait remarquer quand elles sont
bien faites bien dosées sur les
constructions neuves ça tient ça bouge
pas mais ce que je voudrais dire est-ce
qu'on est préparé que vous dire en tout
cas sur la question de l'urgence des
plans communaux de sauvegarde de la
façon de se mettre tout de suite au
service des habitants moi j'ai vu trois
mères il y en a un qui agent immobilier
donc il savait de quoi il parlait tout
de suite sur les questions immobilières
l'autre qui a fait de l'action
humanitaire toute sa vie en Haïti
qu'avec lui les tremblements de terre
bien plus important que celui qu'il a eu
dans sa commune et il était Vincent
froid extraordinaire et le troisième qui
est infirmier aux urgences et qui a pris
aussi les choses avec beaucoup de
sang-froid et je crois que ça dénote
aussi cette capacité qu'on a sur des
événements qu'on attend pas parce que le
maire qui a vécu ça Haïti en revenant
dans son village natal en étant mère je
pense qu'il s'attendait pas à vivre un
tremblement de terre mais on voit aussi
qu'on sait affronter ces choses là mais
bien sûr la question des normes et le
compte beaucoup donc on n'est pas tant
démunis que ça mais simplement sur les
questions de la culturation au risque
merci de Jefferson merci beaucoup
regarde la ligne de Sud-Ouest examen le
sprint final c'est à la Une de sud-ouest
et Jefferson on se retrouve jeudi on
reparlera évidemment de cette loi de
programmation militaire à jeudi
Jefferson merci beaucoup allez merci
d'avoir été avec nous et on suivra
évidemment l'examen de cette pas de
programmation militaire tout au long de
la semaine dans cette émission dans 20
minutes dans le club des territoires
résultat de notre baromètre mensuel au
doxa pour les chaînes parlementaires et
la presse régionale quelle image
avez-vous de la nuque et du RN réponse
dans 20 minutes d'abord on accueille
notre prochaine invité Jean-Christophe
de rej